you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman just calm
and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game okay you know it's been a
while since I've played this and the
last time I did I got smashed so let's
see what we get the most committal start
to a chess game in my opinion at least
the Grob okay uh how about the h3 yeah
sure
I feel like g5 is a bit overextended so
let's see what we get I have been
planning to me Bishop takes pawn with c4
Queen b3 and putting some light square
pressure on the Queen side so let's see
what we get um how about we try and poke
around at the d5 pawn c4 Knight c3 on d5
94 maybe I could rely upon the e4 square
hmm going there straightaway okay I
don't see any reason to just pull the
trigger on Knight d2 into e4 could have
also considered maybe Knight f3 first
okay I'm regretting my decision to not
play the knight out first I'd like to
have met this move with g5 but it's just
not happening is it we're gonna have to
make a gambit of it
let's see maybe I could pick up the
bishop pair and try to show some
compensation I doubt that there is any
though do I even take
this Bishop a push hmm I don't want to
take how about this maybe I do want to
take in meet a bishop takes G for a move
with Queen b3 maybe that could be a bit
uncomfortable because for the moment the
queen is tied down to the defense of the
bishop queen here she's overloaded I
could take this pawn Knight takes bishop
and then I get the Queen he could be
kicked at any moment let's see how this
is defended if b6 that's pretty ugly
Bishop back interesting move let's do
this I can meet f6 with c5 I'm preparing
the queenside castle as well interesting
let's develop maybe I should have
captured the bishop when I had the
chance but I don't know okay I guess I'm
having to I have to take now right do I
have something better maybe this is an
opportunity to play this move c5
because I am on the night seems
interesting let's do it and maybe I even
jump into d6 one day on takes Knight
Queen takes Knight with check there's a
queen a5 check as well I'm looking to
just get castled and maybe my rook
enters they have a pretty backward Queen
side development let's see
certainly lively Knight d6 no Queen
exchange didn't expect that okay let's
go with the Queen exchange or take the
knife first hmm now let's take
Queen first because if I took here first
and night would recapture and then if I
took the Queen the night would improve
here so I think in this position I take
the bishop yeah I think I could do this
with the idea to give a check if they
take my night I can oh I think I just
miscalculated first I was hallucinating
with something here I thought I had
Knight d6 check and then taking the
bishop I miscalculated there hmm
I'm losing a piece now no fun I I saw
the wrong night here
whoops okay let's see if we can make the
best out of this hmm
that stinks okay well let's take care
and then I guess take this pawn
I thought there was something there too
I didn't belong in that piece all right
how do we stand on my down a full-piece
I'm down a full-piece let's keep that
night around he has to work some magic
and the d6 square I don't think I want a
castle for some reason king d2 feels
more comfortable I don't think I have to
go straight in for that let's get the
king up right now yeah
tough day Bishop out 96 I don't think
I'm threatening to capture because the
rook enters the scene I have to play
fast to have an eye on the clock here
that was a sharp position early huh 96
let's go right in for that and maybe I
could do this move if they take the beep
on I have rook e1 into b7 maybe they
look to trade off my night with 9 c8
sensible any trades are likely favoring
black yeah I think I would play that
move ok they're going for this a bit of
a shock to allow this kind of counter
play another piece to enter here there
at the two-minute mark Collett I Britian
my my bishop my bishop can spring to
life by way of a 5 and I'm scooping up
this pawn so I think this is some
unnecessary complications they're
allowing
let's do this without too much thought
then he takes pawn ahead rook takes
Knight and then I could take the rook
also there's this move I should have
considered that but can't hurt to open
up the bishops eyes right finally I'll
see this pawn can be captured hmm
let's stay really active this seems
pretty active right here that rook goes
too far isn't this just winning the
piece back Knight b5 that's so easy to
get out of the pin is it that move all
right well let's do this for starters
there's a knight check here but I'm
gonna step up and go straight into the
the the center 106 let's give that a
push rook feels like he's close to
trapped huh Wow completely blind okay
how about we do King up right now hmm
missing many many many things hmm
something straightaway I have nothing at
all
and I know I guess I'm gonna try this
and they want to take this pawn
expecting a six usually I don't even
know what to expect at this point having
haven't done very well with guessing
okay maybe I get my King in the center
no flush him back super active King
that's about it down a full-piece still
let's put them back in a pin make life a
little bit difficult
stop that pond from going any further 23
seconds he has to come both come back
over to defend the night a night
struggling to find some squares King d7
I guess King da King here is pretty
active let's go back bishop c6 the
knight can't move because I have this
let's give it a check here and then come
back over perpetual let's see what they
do the King could run to see a king b7
rook d6 king c8 that's what's gonna
happen I guess they're down on time so
am i it's a rat race don't get mated
wild and crazy' pawn here
I gotta track him down where's my Bishop
going if he's attacked I guess here
don't have much time got to get out of
skewers there's gonna be a time when I
guess it is lucky duck
oh the grub that's why I don't play the
grub
oh what a messy messy messy game so many
things missed and I just had some
activity and that's it objectively
busted from a very early point let's see
what the let's just dive into the
analysis Wow a 50 move game g4 that's
why I haven't played this in so long
yeah the idea here is to me Bishop takes
pawn with immediate pressure on the
light squares c4 takes for taking on b7
if they reinforce that could do
something like this or maybe even Queen
b3 straight away anyhow just this is the
rough idea with this opening and that's
pretty much the extent of my knowledge
yeah I I should have been around this
point instead of Knight d2 this move so
I can meet this with g5 but as it played
out it was very lively here and I just
completely missed that I was dropping a
piece I miscalculated I'd be interested
a little bit here to see what the
computer says because I do have
development I'm down upon but hey I'm
one square or one move away in my rook
is entering I think maybe there's
something for me here Queen d5 right
around this point
yes if I'm going to take the Queen I
have to next just jump right into d6 I
was thinking it was this night I was
losing by capturing this Bishop I
thought after pawn takes Knight it was
the other night that was being captured
for some reason and that I could play
this move and after King takes Bishop
Knight takes Bishop there and it's still
very messy I didn't mean to go all the
way back there but yeah so I guess right
here I should be playing after Queen
takes Queen the knight straight in with
check yeah and then they have to take
them out
right cuz if yeah I'm on the bishop and
I'm ready to take this pawn out and if
he goes double isolated pawns it's too
much this is a super valuable if there's
one pawn in blacks position that I
assign is the most valuable would be
this guy right here is without him
they're just two sitting ducks so Locke
would have to take and then I'm
threatening I have some dark square
pressure I have the bishop pair but can
I really even crash through here they
see six seems pretty easy enough maybe
I'd have to invest some more material
somehow I can exchange sacrifice just to
get at this poem that might be something
no certainly messy rook c1 hmm yeah I
don't know about this streaky mmm I
wonder if I could do something else like
a knight move hitting this pawn but
that's conveniently defended oh no I
felt pretty interesting right around
here
very lively position I gave up a square
by playing c4 Queen d5 should I just go
straight in for Bishop takes Bishop I
wonder huh also I had that a different
idea where I could have captured the
bishop right away something about that
said to me you know what I should focus
more on just development instead of
grabbing the bishop and helping black to
develop some I don't know I think this
will be one that the computer at least
up until this moment here will offer
some interesting suggestions because
from this point on it's just busted I'm
down a piece and there's no this isn't
any kind of compensation what do we got
three four five six
there's not I have a pond for not enough
I don't think that they should have
captured on before this is just allowing
me to coordinate some pieces and yeah I
thought that night c8 would have been
best and my night doesn't have a square
really I think I go to b5 but then this
is an opportunity to play a five and
that's a nice way to activate the rook
in the corner this exchange cannot be
avoided and soon I'm gonna be under some
fire my own king meanwhile this bishop
tall pond syndrome okay well Messi game
let's have a look at it see what uh kind
of tips stockfish gives us ok stockfish
let us see how bad g4 really is yeah
it's pretty bad that's why you're not
gonna see the computers playing g4 at
all legs already better but that's just
into the objective evaluation still have
to punish it right and that's so easy to
do
ok nothing fancy just yet it's not
really so much a fan of flinching right
away ninety seven instead holding this
pawn duo so some a little something is
given up for me the e4 squares on the
radar
h5 is glued reply Knight f3 is better
here okay I didn't even consider
capturing okay I just jumped into e4 so
I didn't have to lose upon but it's
still holding around the same valuation
that we had from move one g4 even though
I'm down upon interesting Bishop takes
g4 Queen b3 but ship returns at yeah it
is awkward is it not because playing
this Wow the possibilities for him now
right
c6 doesn't have defensive upon defense
vie upon hate f3 I have some squares for
my pieces in this Queen coming down
along this diagonal possibilities for c5
hitting the bishop this pawn is ever
moving so he returns home it's a
sensible move you know
because again for this one moment the
Queen doesn't have the the time to do
this I could take on d6 or I thought
just take here as well with this being
the tactic and I'm up a piece unlike the
game so the bishop returns Bishop g5
Knight f3
hmm and now I am better with the move I
played c5 so right around here is where
I could have done one better
so on Queen d5 what should I have done
Knight d6 hmm oh okay well I was I did
throw the knight in to d6 when I was
going through without the computer but
only after first exchanging Queens ah
here's another way to look at it by
taking the Queen's I'm giving up the c6
square to the Queen Knight
so duck nests so jumping straight in
Bishop takes pawn takes yeah this is
different isn't it Queen takes pawn on
takes and now I'm on this guy and if
black wants to defend the pawn directly
Knight d7 well this is the only way to
defend it I believe if he's going here
this is a little bit awkward and still
have some work to do follow up move rook
to a5 forget about this structure it's
more about piece activity in this type
of position rook a a5 Wow how do we
stand here one two three four five six
they have seven ponds versus my six but
I have a lot of activity all my pieces
are out and about Wow interesting
position so from here I shouldn't have
captured the Queen but instead drop my
knight straight in because I captured
now I'm simply worse yeah I should have
just seen it as maybe I think in the
back of my mind I still had us had this
positional mentality where I'd I don't
want to allow my pawns to be doubled but
I should not be in that frame of mind
here there should definitely be an
adjustment in this sharp position it's
more about the piece activity and I
shouldn't be allowing this pawn to
improve and open up that new square for
the Queen night I should just pull the
trigger on Knight to d6 straight away
knowing that there isn't this kind of
wind because I'm getting the night
so I once I went in for this I'm just
worse from this point on and well I
could go one step further I'm just
losing because of this and again I was
thinking somehow my knight was able to
play here after my night was captured
seeing seeing the wrong stuff there so I
guess at this point we could just see
how black could have killed me
much easier again I didn't like that
they captured my beep on it's on it's
allowing unnecessary complications rook
b1 of course it's it's still going to be
winning but yeah to even allow that kind
of activity where you're in a pin and
maybe I could be piling up on the pin
yeah well so I could actually go right
in for that right now hmm
look at look at that shift right there
to pawn advantage collet and now it's
pretty even ish huh with Knight b5 right
away you know what I didn't see I just
thought oh well I take this fish up and
then you know III thought it would just
be an even exchange like if they take
here but I'm actually scooping up two
pieces I get to take the knight and I
get to take both nights I didn't see
this idea I really didn't I only saw it
as far as I'm gonna win this piece but
if I get him I'm getting him next by
force hmm so I should have gone in for
that and this would have forced the rook
back over to c8 hmm do I have a
perpetual here Knight d6 I guess I have
some sort of a perpetual here notice
that trying to do move like this allows
a bishop takes c6
and then I get the rook I'm winning
sharp stuff I should have went piled
right up on the the pinch piece but
because I reacted to this rook takes
Bishop no good they take
pun and now it's even because of night
b5 and I played that and now Knight
takes a seven
hmm I guess I could be bouncing back and
forth here
now that the knight isn't defending a
seven Wow I had some chances even though
I'm down a piece here and it all starts
again
it all starts because I even have this
rookie in the ball game you know taking
that beep on like taking the beep on and
from here I don't think there's anything
more yeah just to emphasize once more if
I captured when it comes over here if I
capture on a seven the rook is kicked
from the defense of the night and my
knight simply returns we can have this
kind of Perpetual going on or repetition
of position I should say it'll be a draw
computer pointed out ah a knight to c7
or Knight to c4 move isn't that just
helping improve my King some like c8 9 a
7 yeah
just bounce back and forth on a 7 and B
5 there but getting back to the point
where they allowed some counter play
after this v4 move b6 is a move and I
think right around here I was saying
that isn't Knight c8 a fine move yeah
this works as well looking to exchange
Knights best is apparently be 595 mm
okay I guess that's a little bit awkward
and now it's pointing out night to b6
okay this is a little too messy my
knight in the end I guess is gonna be
trapped and he remains a dummy here tall
pond especially with the knight on e5
super block a derp but yeah to to even
take the beep on I mean something like a
six just holding
the Knights position is good enough you
know it'll take me quite some time if
I'm ever playing a for now things are
different
notice Knight takes pawn rook b1 can now
be met with a5 my pawn has created some
holes on b3 and b4 notice that little
difference a six and only after a four
chop tack now there's just some defense
here and I don't have this a3 move to
kick the night away like I did in the
game how did it play out Knight takes
rook b1 the knight was defended and now
I have a three nice little detail here
regarding the a pawns first a6 and then
if this now you could take and anchor
your knight in to b4 allowed black
allowed some counter play had some
opportunities to draw surprisingly
enough and yeah sharp game I don't think
it's winning or drawing at any point
from this point on just confirming
things I think this dot 0 that just
popped up there was just a little
doesn't mean it's an objective draw it's
just recognizing it as this a repetition
type thing but now it's always winning
here for black ooh
spoke spoke too soon well I could take
the bishop here Wow
yeah what do i do just make an excuse
that it was time pressure on this point
it was but yeah what a sharp game I
could have captured here and then
captured the rook even position Wow some
draws along the way in this and Grob
opening I don't think I'm gonna be
playing this one again I don't know
what do you think you play the grab let
me know in the comment section below
certainly makes for a fun game and I
don't know if you got anything out of it
but I hope it was at least a little fun
to watch this one so that's all for now
take care bye